hi I'm Robert Downey Jr and I'm
Christopher Nolan and this is the wired
auto complete interview
I probably should have taken my blood
pressure medication
does Robert Downey Jr have tattoos I
have six that's the sixth one and that
was the Avengers cast tattoo that
happened in the evening of the premiere
for Infinity War Scarlett got it first
then Chris Evans got it then I got it
then Jeremy Renner got it then Chris
Hemsworth got it even though he's a
little tentative about it and seemed to
overreact to the pain and then Mark
Ruffalo said I'm not getting that tattoo
I don't want to be part of your
Hollywood inside game to which I
applauded him
does Robert Downey Jr do his own stunts
in a year
where the level and magnitude of stunts
may be in an all-time high I am
committing to do less stunts every year
for the rest of my career but yes does
Robert Downey Jr like AC DC come on
course Back in Black from the first Iron
Man
there's your sound bite buddy does
Robert Downey Jr like Gwyneth Paltrow I
do not like Gwyneth Paltrow
I absolutely adore her like a sister
like a sister that you may have made out
with a few times
while still liking her
that's for you okay I'd like to actually
try this inverted just to make this even
more impossible there we go this is
gonna work a treat why
Christopher Nolan now that in and of
itself is just a good question
why Christopher Nolan doesn't use CGI I
find CGI however versatile it is but it
always tends to feel a little safe to me
I think if you want something to have a
bit of bite you build the imagery to
have a bit of threat even if it's a
miniature even if it's something very
fake but something real on camera I
think it gives you a better result why
does Christopher Nolan we're in the wise
shoot on film I shoot a film because
it's the highest quality Imaging format
of a device particularly IMAX film large
format film but film uh shows you the
world kind of the way your eye sees it
is it ridiculous for me to give a
serious answer well you're saying that
but
give the people what they want where
does Christopher
sit up
um
where does Christopher Nolan get his
ideas all over the place different on
every film Oppenheimer somebody had been
interested in a long time didn't know
that much about the specifics of his
story then came to the book American
Prometheus and that absolutely got me
hooked so in the case of Oppenheimer the
idea I mean gosh I trace it right back
to like you know as a kid in the 80s and
we all thought we were going to die in
nuclear Armageddon absolutely you
remember sting had that song Russians
Russians oppenheimer's deadly toys yes
how can I save my little boy's deadly
toy there is no Monopoly of Common Sense
on either side of the political offense
we share the same biology
regardless of ideology what might just
save us me and you where is Christopher
Nolan
from where am I from born in London uh
but I'm half American half English my
mother's American I've grown up kind of
both sides of the Atlantic but
originally from England how come your
brother doesn't have your accent he has
his own accent uh yeah I know that's I
know that he speaks the way he speaks
but he sounds like he's from America and
you don't yes but that's the American
thing where you say how come you have an
accent and he doesn't to which he said
well he does have an accident it's an
American accent you're right uh just
because of when uh my parents were
living different countries so he went to
school in America I went to school in
England so you kind of get fixed with
that accent
sorry no crew members were harmed in the
execution of this dalliance how did
Robert Downey Jr become Iron Man it was
God's will
that's it really well and a pretty good
screen test but I'll really tell you
what happened is the same weekend I did
a movie called Kiss Kiss Bang Bang John
Favreau did a movie called Zathura they
both tanked and we were both really
hungry to try to do something that would
make an impact and when Iron Man came
out everyone that knew me and loved me
said this will do until the Dark Knight
comes out
and here we are now what are Robert
Downey Jr Hobbies I have one Hobby and
that I take classic cars and I do
um Eco Resto mods on them thus take old
cars and then make them more uh energy
efficient and climate friendly any
follow-up questions to that no because
it's getting dangerously close to a plug
for your TV show you're right and we're
here doing open home am I limited to
three or four yeah
who does Robert Downey Jr play in
Oppenheimer Lewis Lichtenstein Strauss
he was the head of the atomic energy
commission he was a very uh conservative
patriotic American he and Oppenheimer
were verging on Nemesis
none at all uh yeah complicated man he
was a complicated guy unlike me as you
can see it takes one to play one
what year was Robert Downey Jr Junior on
SNL 1985. oft considered the worst
season in the history of SNL I got back
on foreign
suitcase boy
well no that never made it to air
and that's the one that sticks out can
Robert Downey Jr play piano only well
enough to compose at a medium to high
level
what if Christopher Nolan directed The
Avengers well that is the Multiverse
conundrum having work with you on
Oppenheimer there'd probably be a lot
too much Tony Stark you'd be running
away with the movie a little bit like I
didn't and even more and uh not liking
ucg would you be prepared to get on one
of those jet packs the ones they make
for real that do this yeah if
Christopher Nolan had directed The
Avengers we would still be shooting it
Christopher Nolan's best movie the one
I'm promoting I mean that's how that
works right I'm telling you and I've
seen every single film you've ever done
Oppenheimer is the culmination of your
life's work and it is a freaking
Masterpiece brother thank you and that
is the God's honest truth thank you and
now back to my faux sincerity which
works better
what makes Christopher Nolan tick unique
he's supposed to answer this yeah I was
going to say I'm leaving that to you he
already told you he's British so you're
never going to get that answer out of
him
there's such a Mystique around you that
I think sometimes people feel
intimidated and then when you actually
get in proximity to you and particularly
shooting a film it's arguably the least
judgmental most nurturing environment I
could have ever imagined being in he's
kind of like The Wizard of Oz except I
think he dresses cooler
that's going to travel
moving on just remember this was
someone's idea to pair us up here what
is Christopher Nolan's California
driver's license number I'm sorry first
movie my first movie is a film that Emma
and I produced together called following
we shot it on black and white 16
millimeter film we were working full
time with a group of friends and we
would shoot one day a week for about a
year we put it together that way you
would never know it seems even your
first film felt so complete what degree
does Christopher Nolan have uh I have an
English degree from UCO in London my
gosh
are these edible no okay that's all
right
is Robert Downey Jr Tom Holland's
Godfather if if by Godfather you mean I
do light yard work for him on Thursdays
and detail his car every other Saturday
then yes is Robert Downey Jr related to
Charlie Chaplin not that I'm aware of
odlean spirit yep uh speaking of great
directors Attenborough I got a complete
education on Cinema and enthusiasm and
trust and love how old were you when you
did them I was 26 and you know what he's
like you he just cries a lot more
um very sensitive is Robert Downey Jr
going to ask Chris Nolan to cry on cue
for him you're goddaughter
go in tight this is his screen tester is
Robert Downey Jr a vegan now I'm a
vegetarian occasional pescetarian if I
start feeling lightheaded I might have
some shrimp or maybe a steelhead trout
no scallops Just For the Halibut I might
occasionally uh I like a bit of uh soul
I don't know why that means Seoul I
guess it's what goes beneath the surface
I don't want this to end I mean we're
used to a bit of joviality but this is
this is another level
for you how Christopher Nolan became a
director I started making films when I
was a little kid borrowed my dad's Super
8 camera I was about seven years old I
started making films and I've kind of
never stopped seven seven who is
Christopher Nolan's cinematographer uh
well you can answer this one
great Dutch Director of Photography and
not afraid to pick up an IMAX camera and
hold it on his shoulder how did
Christopher Nolan recreate a nuclear
explosion well we don't want to give
away the tricks too much didn't ucg try
to come up with methods from the visual
effects of special effects Department
that were very small microscopic things
that look huge but that also some giant
big bangs out in the desert that were
pretty spectacular to uh live through
and that is how you give an answer
without giving an answer is Christopher
Nolan a physicist no I am not a
physicist I've always been interested in
physics and I've done a lot of films
that involved looking into ideas of
physics purely and amateur I don't know
if I buy that do you want another take
no I'm good okay
what was Robert Downey Jr's first job uh
my first job was working at the Indian
Walk shoe store on Broadway and 83rd
Street I made it about 10 shifts before
I was fired for my Sticky Fingers
okay what music does Robert Downey Jr
listen to everything from uh prokofiev
to I'm into sleaford Mods lately and
also uh Indio Downey my firstborn got an
album coming out
fantastic what is Robert Downey Jr
personality type do you want to take
this one no I'm really interested to
know what you can say I usually Play
Type A personalities no no come on come
on come on you're not getting away with
type A that's too technical I'm curious
curious I'm loyal I'm easily bored I
thought you were gonna go with easy if
you remember there and I was gonna shake
my head up yeah because I'm easy
what glasses does Robert Downey Jr wear
that was a high degree of difficulty
tape Hole by the way do you see how he's
mastered it already uh all kinds of
glasses I love all glasses and a
Shameless plug I'm probably gonna start
my own glasses company do you want to
just go in tight on this
Downy design exchange they'll be out in
probably 6 9 12 16 18 months depending
on my personality type
does Christopher Nolan storyboard only
select sequences I don't storyboard much
but if there's something that people
really need to to take a look at you
know use them as a jumping off point for
departments I did not know that does
Christopher Nolan have social media I do
not that is a pointless question if you
know anything about him because you
would think it was 1847 the way he
communicates
and this one just says Christopher Nolan
Christopher Nolan influences influences
always like to talk about Ridley Scott
huge fan of his standard Kubrick Terence
Malik Nicholas Rogue I mean they're just
just so many greats too many influences
to name them Nicholas he's a really good
poll Christopher Nolan and Killian
Murphy and Killian Murphy mile Franklin
uh we worked together for 20 years one
of the great actors of his generation or
any other and we've done six films
together this is six options this is six
but this is the first time got to use
him as a leading man yeah first met him
he's screen tested for Batman and I
think we're both kind of knew he
probably wasn't right for Batman but his
test was so exciting that the studio was
okay for me to cost him as the villain
I whispered it because I I have a
problem talking about DC characters I
don't know if I was programmed or not
but I was in this room with a lot of
flashing lights once long story thanks
Kevin
well that's done look what you got this
is the most ectomorphic this man has
ever been
well Chris Robert we made it through all
the boards I thought it was fun I think
the time just flew by flew by I learned
a bit and learned a bit until next time
[Music]